foreign
um
[Music]
thank you very much members um
welcome to rochford district council's
remote meeting of the licensing appeals
committee and welcome to anyone watching
this via the live stream
first of all we go to agenda item one
apologies for absence
um i have apologies from um
councillor macpherson
counselor
mr jim gooding um i think there are some
other sonia
no those are the only apologies that
we've received in the office uh uh
council williams okay thank you very
much
um
substitute item agenda two substitute
members
none have been notified in advance
uh gender item three non-members
attending
yeah arthur laureen's
been thrown out of the meeting she can't
get back in i'll send her the uh link
again thank you
thank you
are there any non-members attending so i
don't think there are on there
they're on and uh
thank you
a genuine item
agenda item 4 minutes for the meeting
held on the 30th of september by the
minutes of the meeting held on the 30th
of september 2021 agreed members
i will assume so unless anyone clicks on
their raised hand icon
as i can see now i presume that is
accepted thank you
gender item five to receive declarations
of interest members are there any
declarations of interest
yeah council of carter
um i declare a non-pecuniary interest as
i'm a hackney taxi driver
one item seven thank you council carson
thank you
no others that i can see uh gender
martin six consultation of the review of
the statement of the licensing policy
gambling act 2005.
um i'm going to ask steve greener and
the council's principal last year to
introduce the report
thank you steve
good evening thank you everyone
this report is to consider the statement
of licensing under the gambling act 2005
for the period of time between 2022 and
2025
following a statutory consultation with
the public
section 349 of the gambling act of 2005
requires the council to determine and
publish its licensing policy
every
three years
the council's current policy is for the
period ending the 30th of january 2022.
the policy was uh revised and approved
for consultation between the 10th of
september 2001 and the 5th of november
2001.
uh sorry
2021. the draft policy was circulated
for consultation to these
those identified in the report and the
draft policy was displayed at the
council offices and on the council's
website
and a copy of the final policy is
attached as appendix a
the licensing team contacted 50
interested parties including the
gambling commission the gambling
anonymous and local authorities at the
conclusion of the consultation period
the licensing
team received just one response from a
solicitors acting as consultants for the
trade highlighting a number of policy
areas where the council could clarify um
in relation to definitions
and appendix b is a copy of that letter
and response
the suggested clarification amendments
has been incorporated within the new
policy and these relates to the points
that are listed in 3.3
there is no reason for the consultation
responses not to recommend the adoption
of the policy to take effect from the
31st of january 2022
this policy will is next due for renewal
by the 31st of january 2025.
in relation to the recommendations it is
recommended to the council that the
statement of licensing gambling policy
is
approved for adoption and publication
and that's the end of the summary report
thank you thank you very much mr uh
greener um does anybody have any
questions or needs any points of
clarification for this
right
thank you um
members of paragraph 8.1
maybe i'm thick and i don't know so i've
never really been in a betting shop
what is the difference it mentions to
highlight the difference between gaming
machines and betting machines what is
the difference
yeah gambling machines and vetting
machines are different based on their
values as to how much that you can have
as a stake and also how much you can pay
out so that is the difference and then
what i've done is i've incorporated the
wording that is being provided by the
gambling commission um just to provide a
little bit of additional clarity to the
members of the public like say that
don't fully understand the
requirements so we've incorporated that
within the policy
thank you
do we have any other questions
right members thank you um
at paragraph 8.1 on page 6.2 there is
one recommendation which recommends to
council
that the statement of licensing policy
gambling act 2005 22 2022
to 2025 be approved for adoption and
publication
members i will move the recommendation
from the chair do i have a seconder
i have a second uh
we have a choice
counselor mrs marine shaw thank you
all right
um can is everybody happy to use
the the show of hands
the the the icon or a show of hands
so could i see a show of hands on the
vote on
for on behalf of this please
believe that's unanimous
yes
chairman as unanimous thank you
are you okay to proceed uh sonia
yes please chairman
thank you members
um
motion is carried thank you all those oh
no no we don't need that bit sorry
um
yeah it's item seven now please uh uh
chairman i am yeah i should item seven
proposal to introduce an earn as you
learn private hire drivers badge
steve uh greener the council's principal
license will introduce the report
thank you very much this is a request to
introduce a earn as you learn private
hire drivers badge to encourage new
drivers into the trade
there is currently a national license
driver shortage and since the pandemic
the council has also seen a reduction in
the number of drivers
there's been a number of reasons for the
decline
one which has included the drivers have
mended their working patterns and
focusing on daytime trade rather than
the evening and weekend trade
this change has had a knock-on effect to
the number of licensed vehicles that
operates predominantly on a friday and
saturday night across the district
the council licensing team has met and
has been working closely with the four
main operators known as the trade
to look together to look at short-term
and long-term solutions
the proposal by the group including
ourselves is
was identified that the current
requirements is in place to obtain a
hackney carriage driver's license takes
approximately six months for the entire
process
before the driver can obtain their
license to work
for those who are seeking alternative
employment they have to take this time
scale into consideration with the
knowledge test that may not work for up
to six months while they complete their
application process
i have outlined in 3.4 the proposal that
would require an applicant to complete
before their badge was issued
so firstly they would submit an
application form and confirming they
have a rights to work within the uk and
also they'll be working for an existing
operator
pay the application fee
demonstrate they have a right to work in
the uk which either by passport
pass our mass and english suitability
tests comply with the requirements of
the disclosure and buying service which
is the old crb
comply with the requirements around the
dvla driving license requirements
comply with the group 2 medical's
requirements which
all bus drivers and lorry drivers also
have to comply with
and also comply with the requirements of
providing the reference
within six months of receiving their
badge we will ask them to also pass
their disability awareness course
to also complete their safeguarding
training
and also as well
past their enhanced driving assessment
as well
within nine months of them being issued
the temporary badge they will also be
asked to pass their full hackney
carriage driver's knowledge test
if they fail to meet this requirement
then the driver's license will
automatically expire the expiry date
printed on the badge which is nine
months from the date that we issue
if the operator or the licensing team
are aware of any concerns relating to
the driver the badge will be suspended
immediately
the driver cannot reapply to rocha
district council until 12 months has
passed from the expiry of the earn as
you learn badge
we have looked at this and i've included
specifically around risk implications
and around reputation rep
reputational risks to the council
and we believe this is a low
reputational risk because of the number
of additional measures that we've asked
for in advance
and we'll be working closely with the
operators within the licensing team to
ensure that any concerns that are raised
around a specific driver
additionally looking at strategic sort
of risks
additional
new drivers will help reduce any
safeguarding concerns that may raise
specifically late into friday and
saturday nights it has been identified
that the waiting time for some pickups
can be up to two hours at the present
time
and if with a vehicle that's being
booked
the current loan numbers of drivers is
also impacting on the travelling public
and specifically those with limited
mobility
the lack of drivers indicate those that
are reliant on the misfits of transport
could be disadvantaged with the lack of
drivers and vehicles that are out there
at the present time
i'll jump into the recommendation
it
is proposed that the committee resolves
that the russia district council hackney
carriage and private hired drivers sorry
vehicles
and operators conditions are amended to
allow the earn as you learn scheme to
operate and that the effectiveness of
the scheme is to be reviewed after 12
months in partnership with the trade and
that is the end of the summary report
thank you mr greener
thank you are there any questions for
mr greener
first of all we have councillor fd
a couple of questions uh
mr greener um
one you say that the uh
my main problems is friday and saturday
night
um
i'm a little bit concerned that the
safeguarding training can be done in the
six months after they start
maybe it might be better to do it before
they start depending on how many courses
rdc until we put more than two on a year
is that why it's six months or
do we put them on when they want
the knowledge schools that work with the
operators um provides the actual
training themselves they're actually
accredited we have a number of approved
contractors um so there's no reason why
i can't include that within the the
first criteria if that's the requirement
of of this committee and and also you
just said there where people having
um disability
again you say that's a that's a problem
at the moment you lack of drives with
that surely they must need the training
for that too
maybe that might be a good one before
they start
and the last question is where it says
and they've got a wait a year if they
don't pass the knowledge is that the
same as like a normal taxi driver don't
they get can't they not take it within
28 days or something can they get free
chances
yes that's correct in relation to our
conditions around the knowledge test
they're allowed to take free um tests
and if they fail their third test then
they have to wait 12 months before they
can reapply again to that people so
you're just saying they
so so they're just taking one test or do
they have the chance to take free tests
they will still have the chance to take
three tests that's fine okay that's that
wasn't clear thank you
thank you councillor stanley
sorry chairman i wasn't quite ready for
that
in front of me um yeah two questions uh
yep um
to
some some of these tests that we're
asking them to do
um could that be the other way around
where they can take those tests
before the
six months
um and also my other
question is
um
the the the any effect of the fair of of
that driver if that driver doesn't
know the route or what is the route for
the charge to the customer um because
he's learning the route or learning the
the the to be a taxi driver um it could
end up with with a an over charge or the
wrong route if you like and make it
longer so that it will charge even more
so i i have to
sort of i'll worry about that because
he's learning the route uh does he know
you know the thing is he we need to be
confident that they know the roots of
the what is allocated in in the way of
charging um
i i don't see how this can work if
you're learning the routes and you know
your your charge rates will go up
thank you cal sterling yes in relation
to this um it relates to private hire
which means that the booking is made in
advance so they cannot work on the
actual taxi ranks they have to
work for an operator so they will know
where they're going from and where they
were going to so they will know
before they even do the collection as to
to where they're going um if we find out
that drivers are taking the longer route
that's clearly where i'll be working
very closely with the operators to look
at these sort of figures if there's a
specific driver is is flagging up to us
that they are taking the wrong route
a lot of the time then obviously i it
brings into question as to why they are
actually doing that um and then if we do
an investigation in conjunction with the
operator then we could effectively
suspend that uh driver
does that help
yeah the other point was that uh can the
can they
earn as you learn sort of thing
can some of the
uh
criteria be be put in advance of
the six months yeah
absolutely if they are keen to
um complete a lot of this there's
nothing to say that they can't complete
it the whole thing within a shorter time
period um it was just to give them a
rough indication of a time scale to work
to
they then outlined to the applicants and
to the operators this is what we would
expect them to achieve if they achieve
that beforehand that's absolutely
brilliant um it's what we're looking at
trying to introduce here is a fast track
system to try and one address the issues
with the numbers of drivers but also as
well
to support the the trade as well um but
also get the drivers through
so we are open to to helping what we can
so hill councillor stanley thank you
very much thank you no councillor phil
shaw
thank you chairman um
mr greener um
when
the app the
learn as you
license runs out they can't apply for 12
months
is that another earners you learn
badge or have they got to go on to
something else
uh that depends on whether the scheme is
still continuing after the 12-month
period
sorry
fair enough um
that was it says that um
they would a requirement be on the
operators to work with the license
holders to what is it going to be a time
limit
for them to
do that to get their full license
yes absolutely like say we will once we
issue the badge the initial badge they
then have nine months to complete the
rest of all the other requirements that
we have if they don't complete that then
the badge will automatically expire
and we won't allow a renewal of that
badge and then they would have to
reapply again whether they apply as a
private hire driver or as a handy
carriage driver
but if we added that in there that they
couldn't apply within 12 months if they
did apply in advance
i would imagine that they will be
appealing against our conditions and and
maybe um have to come in front of
yourselves to explain as to why they
feel that they should be
given different um
treatment in relation to the conditions
so going back to my first question um
you said you know mine they might not be
running in 12 months time if it was
running would they
be allowed to do the
you know the um
same course again or would they then
have to go on to the
to the normal um route of doing it we
would treat them as a new applicant like
anyone else so they would have to do the
whole process from scott from start
again
okay thank you okay thank you council
sure uh councillor michael hoy
thank you chairman
um
some of my points have been raised
already but i just want to
understand it more clearly i think um
council fd point about the safeguarding
course particularly um was interesting
because i believe we used to run those
courses ourselves
and now we don't
so the cost has gone up and i think cost
of becoming a
taxi driver in rockford has gone up
quite a lot over the last few years um
which sorry i've raised my hand again
which may be one of the problems however
i agree with councillor fd and i'm not
sure if he proposed it or not if he did
i'd like to
to second it to that we that we um
put the um disability training in the
safeguard training
before
they can actually start driving because
i think that's really important and i
would just like to pick up this again
this happened last time in the licensing
committee that the equality and
diversity implications
do not mention this they just put a
positive spin on it but they don't
say that there could be a negative
impact if they don't if the taxi drivers
don't have disability training and i
think that that's been missed and i
think we need to look at the way we use
the equality and diversity
um implication part of our reports more
carefully because that was definitely
missed the other
side of it i think counselor phil sure
had a very good point with the um what
you do if you failed the earners you
learn
then you do another one you'll earn as
you learn in 12 months time it
i don't think that's right i think you
should then go on to the normal one
you've got 12 months to
to do your knowledge again there's no
reason why you need to earn as you learn
um so i think it should be a one-time
only you can only do this once
um
apart from that i still have my doubts
about it i'm not sure why
we feel that we should
cut corners in the quality of the
training required for our taxi drivers
just because there's a shortage
um
but they're just the points i'd like to
make so
i'm not sure if i'm voting for it yet or
not but i'll see what other people other
counsellors say
apart from what i've just said thank you
okay uh thank you councillor
so um
i understand that
council fda has put in a um an amendment
and you seconded it so but if you don't
mind we'll take the rest of the
questions first and see how we go from
there
before we put that together
sorry chairman i didn't actually put it
in yet cause i was waiting for anybody
else spoke so it might have been more
than what i'd said
okay
okay wait uh well thank you councillor
mike mike carter
yeah thank you chairman um i'll just
reiterate what steve said there is i
mean being a taxi driver now there is a
major shortage
um
and getting back to councillor stanley's
worry about whether or not they will
cheat on the fairs
i can assure you that most of our
panthers that we pick up know
what the fair should be when where
they're going if they know where they're
going and they know if they've been
cheated and they do phone the office and
let us know if
if someone's uh done a dodgy deal so
but um
what else do i need to say i'd like to
thank steve for his report on this and
his colleagues done a good job well done
steve thank you very much for that
thank you very much now that that was my
main point that most
most people that we pick up if they go
into the hospital or doctors or they hit
they know what the fear should be so if
anybody's doing a funny
they will let us know
right thank you very much for that thank
you we have councillor newport
indicating and also councillor gadson so
i'll trade council in newport first if
you don't mind
my question is was i understand that
there are a shortage of taxi drivers
is this whole scheme just to help to
alleviate the fact that we don't have
enough cab drivers on a friday and
saturday night
yes this is um a main concerns that we
had when talking to the trade was when
is their busy period um when do they
have a lot of calls and this is to
mainly focus on the friday and saturday
nights
it may be that there is a
shortage on other nights
that obviously are then identified with
the trait but specifically
we are focusing on the friday and
saturday nights especially um in high
foot forward areas if there is a big
delay in people being collected and
having to wait around for two hours um
that certainly is a concern for us
certainly within the licensing team but
we can't dictate what hours they work
can we no no
it's not really going to alleviate the
problem if their taxes don't taxi
drivers don't want to work a friday and
saturday night it's not really going to
alleviate that problem
it will certainly address some of the
concerns if we have more drivers out
there and like i say we're working with
the operators as well okay we can't
sort of stipulate that uh
they have to work on a friday and
saturday night that may be something
that the operators themselves bring in
um and maybe one the requirements that
when people are applying uh the
operators might want to apply that
themselves to obviously address their
their shortfalls um in their
areas that they're trying to improve
okay thank you
thank you to help council new hall yes
thank you okay thank you uh councillor
garcin
um
um knowledge been a bit of a barrier in
order for people to become taxi drivers
i'm just wondering how essential is for
knowledge with with um sat navs etcetera
that um most mini cab companies use now
so
um
is that something we've taken into
account that sat navs would also help
with
directions a lack of should offset any
risk of overcharging
so i'm wondering if maybe the knowledge
has become a bit too much of a barrier
for people to become drivers
yes we had that discussion um around
standards
and we've also had that conversation
with the drivers as well
they like the knowledge test
it gives also the customers a little bit
of reassurance that uh they have gone
through this
criteria to learn all the roads um the
noise test is not easy um and um i can
see council of the carter nodding his
head um that's had to go through it
himself
um it shows that they are dedicated to
learning the roads the routes
places of interest that is relevant to
rochard um the reason why i've
introduced this like say is technology
has moved on and there is the use of sat
navs and things like that but sometimes
there are times that sat nav
may mislead um may take you down the
wrong routes or might have any sort of
system failures so that's why we would
always ask for the knowledge tests as
well so
um yes we do accept that there are
pre-booked so you will should know where
you're going from a to b but there's
there's always sort of that what-if sort
of situation and um yeah we like um to
still maintain that full knowledge test
okay
thank you before we call caster stanley
um steve i presume that as these are
higher cars if you like the the drivers
will be briefed by their
by by the the company before they do the
the job itself i presume
yes absolutely as i said because they're
pre-booked and every booking has to be
in advanced so they will know where
they're picking up the client from and
where they'll be taking them to
so um they can also do the research
before they even collect the passengers
so they can they should um there
shouldn't be any reason why they should
suddenly go off a different route
unless there is like say there's road
issues that uh i've clearly identified
but we will clearly be working with the
operators if there is a specific driver
that is constantly coming to our
attention that is overcharging or not
behaving as what we would expect them to
do and can you tell me how many how many
drivers we have at the moment on on
licensed by us
yes um funny enough i had a request
only recently and i've got the figures
here in front of me
i've got the figures for
january 2020 i can tell you what those
were for hackney carriage and what we
have is from january 2022
so in january 2020 we had
309 acne carriage drivers
and january 2022 we currently have 215
taxi drivers so we've had a 30 reduction
um in the last two years and what is the
most that we would be able to
to have licensed at any one time is
there a limit no there is no limit we
have not set any limit on the number of
drivers okay thank you councillor
stanley
thank you chairman there was no
disrespect when i mentioned about the uh
value of the taxi driver i know
uh the this is only to do with the
new taxi drivers that are applying to be
taxi drivers and not the
not the ones that are
have already uh got their license and
everything um
it was mentioned just now that the there
is no guarantee
that uh these new taxi drivers
earn as you learn
will be working on a friday or saturday
evening and there's no guarantee that
the
proprietors of the taxi firms can
enforce
that at all um as you know
it's it it just depends on that person
if they want to do
that particular time uh night work or
whatever it is unless you're employed as
doing that and obviously the the the uh
wages if you like
make up that extra uh
night shift if you like um there's been
a lot of talk on the underground at the
moment
for the night shift um and they're
having troubles for people uh being
employed to drive the trains and i think
this is going to be
the same sort of thing i know it's taxes
i don't know what you're saying but
you've got to remember that these people
do have lives they don't they don't
necessarily need to work at night
if they've got sufficient funds during
the day then that's fine often you see
quite a few taxis 13 14 taxis in in the
high streets waiting for their
to to
take people in their taxis so
yeah um
i don't
there there is no criteria to turn
around and say that people these these
earners you learn people will have to
work overnight time and i'm particularly
worried about the
the if you like and i'm gonna say uh
female uh drivers um i'm particularly
worried about that in the way of
um getting them to work of an evening or
night time not the night shift if you
like because there's there is a lot to
deal with i've seen it on the television
you've seen it yourself people being
sick in the back of your cab and that
sort of thing counselor i think we're
moving away from the point here
is there is there anything that we
should be looking at in the way of
security to these uh drivers that or are
we just relying upon the
proprietors of the business okay thank
you um
i would i would presume i'm not sure if
steve can answer this but i would
presume that the the more drivers we
have the more incentive they would be
for them to work
the the later shifts just to to earn the
money i presume
absolutely yes um the more drivers that
we have out there that obviously will
reduce the waiting times but also as
well
we are working very closely with the
operators
we obviously can bring something to the
table but obviously the operators also
have the duty as well
to look at this as well with us um we
said that we will propose this to you um
i know that some of the operators have
already started advertising that they
are actually willing to
pay for the application fee in advance
so there's no initial outlay fee to a
new applicant so they will cover the fee
and then over a period of time they'll
pay it back so they're taking their
responsibilities as well
to try and encourage new drivers into
the system
as you say there's not anything that we
can stipulate on the license around the
times that they can work but that may be
something that the operators themselves
have as part of their terms and
conditions
thank you we have done council daniel
lefty and councillor
phil shaw indicating uh we've discussed
this quite a lot now so we'll let we'll
just have these two councillors and i
was gonna
raise the amendment to the report
so if i could fair
yeah um all i was going to say and
steve's actually mentioned it i mean it
could be down to the operators when
they're looking for new drivers
advertising
i mean they could say these are the
hours we're expecting you to work i mean
yeah that's up to them yeah but i'm
saying you know if they want drivers for
friday and saturday
that they would put that you know this
is the hours within the days we want you
to work so
that hopefully would cover it okay fine
thank you thank you and uh
chairman can i put the
commitment to the report yes please to
remain the report for the disability
awareness and the safeguarding training
to be
to have to take them before they
actually start driving
[Music]
we have a second different council
microwave
uh councillor gavison yeah you have
something quickly to say i was second in
oh we have two seconders spoiled for
choice thank you
all right first of all we need to take a
vote on that uh
on the amendment um so can i see a show
of hands please in favor of the event
the amendment first of all
i believe that's unanimous as far as i
can see
yes
thank you very much so that amendment is
would you like to clarify that amendment
um how do you understand it sonya
[Music]
or would that be best my my
understanding is that um
the uh the the recommendation has been
amended to include the requirement for
um these uh these these drivers to
undertake the safeguarding and
disability training before they start
work
excellent thank you thank you
members of paragraph 8.1 on page 7.5
there are two recommendations uh
two of one of which has been amended and
that's that the rocha district council
hackney carriage and private hire driver
vehicle and operator license conditions
the amendment amended to allow the earn
as you learn scheme to operate
and two that the effectiveness of the
scheme be renewed after 12 months in
partnership with the trade
members i will move the recommendation
from the chair with the appropriate
amendments
do i have a second uh
whoever you want chairman yeah mother
spoiled for choice thank you
are you happy members to vote on block
on both recommendations i will assume
agreement unless you click on the raised
hands icon or raise your hands manually
there seems to be nobody objecting so
voting
now please mute yourself now and tell me
if you are not able to use the
electronic hand icon and raise your hand
manually so it can be counted
both you will be done with the electric
shaft hands all of those in favor of the
recommendations please click on the
raised ankle icon once
or raise your hand
and that's unanimous chairman
okay thank you
thank you members
please lower your electronic hands
you will need them loud before we
continue
um
i believe that's the end of the meeting
as far as i can see now
yes thank you very much for attending
it's much appreciated
thank you for your assistance
thank you good night thank you